So far in this lesson we've discussed sensory memory, short-term or working
memory, and long-term memory. We've also discussed the differing areas of the
brain that are associated with different types of memory such as implicit or
explicit memory. One thing we haven't touched on yet is how emotions can play a
role in remembering a particular life event. Now think back to your own life
and an emotional situation that you remember. Whether graduating from high
school or college, or your first date, or even the funeral of a loved one. Why
is it that we can remember details of these events, but we can't remember what
we wore to the gym two days ago. Well as it turns out, emotions play a key role
in remembering and retrieving information. Let's go take a closer look at this.